moviefirst TV series first Matt's
already argued that we have to have a TV
series first but well he's wrong and an
idiot and we should all tell him to shut
up go comment on this video shut up Matt
so we have the debate movie or
television series first for Stargate I'm
going to argue that we should have a
movie first welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV movie channel
[Music]
all right
so on Tuesday we dropped a video on
Sidetrack by Matt who argued that we
should have a television series first
and not a movie for Stargate but the new
franchise needs to kick off with a TV
series and it would be stupid for them
to do a movie first now don't get me
wrong I know there are some risks that
if Amazon and MGM decide to do a movie
for the Stargate first and then that
movie bombs that it will kill the
franchise instantly
and that's a very pessimistic cowardly
way of looking at the problem I would
say
let them do a movie first let them kick
off the new Stargate franchise in a big
way a cinematic release a movie say 150
million dollar budget some big actors a
big plot a movie that can only be
appreciated on the big screen why not go
big this franchise deserves us going big
doesn't it it would probably be cheaper
to create a television series hey maybe
even two then creating one movie
but the other day we want the Stargate
franchise to be kicked off in a big way
we want the big cinematic list we want
all the interest and attention that a
movie will get that a TV series just
won't
extreme in service series don't get me
wrong they have a lot more impact than
they used to back in the day you've had
very much television actors and movie
actors and movie actors were the
a-listers they were the big boys the TV
actors were always considered you know
just TV actors but nowadays those lines
are seriously blurred you can have
actors A-list actors appear in a
television series and vice versa it
really doesn't matter as much as it used
to
but the cinema does still have the big
draw if we see a big Premiere with the
red carpet Etc it's always a big deal
for a movie and not so much when a
television series does it
also a movie will still attract the big
names we could get some seriously and
properly decent actors in it look at the
Star Wars
when the new Mandalorian series comes
out the Star Wars fans are very excited
we all are we go and watch it we love
the series but when a new Star Wars
movie comes out well everybody loses
their freaking Minds that is a fantastic
Point everyone will lose their minds if
there is a movie comparing it to Star
Wars yeah I absolutely see it but the
problem with Star Wars and I think the
problem with Stargate as well is
the TV shows are just infinitely better
if we're comparing Stargate movies to
Star Wars movies I would much rather
have a Stargate series because the more
recent Star Wars movies absolutely suck
compared to the series you can make
billions of dollars at the box office
now I'm not saying Stargate would do
that but what I'm saying is the cinema
is still the place to go if you want to
make a big impact and if you want to
kick start a new franchise
now I also know there is a risk that
Amazon could decide to go the movie
route and actually go the hard reboot
route map now that is
a concern but everything we've been told
and everything we've heard Whispers
through and actually had confirmed by
Roland Emerick is that Amazon considered
the TV audience to be the ones that are
important and there it is that is why we
need a series before a movie
the Stargate franchise was built on the
TV franchise yes the movie was
successful one of the highest grossing
films of mgm's entire lifetime I agree
wholeheartedly but it wouldn't have been
as popular and it wouldn't have been as
Grand without the TV show
focus on that what we can infer from
that is that actually sg1 SGU and SGA
is the Canon that's important that they
know us fans will lose our fragile
little Minds if they do a hard reboot
particularly after only 15 years you
know if if this was in another 20 years
time and Stargate was something that was
on our TV screens 30 years ago then I
could say I'd say yeah hard reboot but
it's not that long ago sg1 SGA and Su
are still in our screens and they still
look good this is not like when Ronald D
Moore did Battlestar Galactica and you
know you have the original from the 70s
that was on 80s and it looked very set
in the 70s and 80s this is it's not like
that sg1 still stands up today against
any other television on our screens it's
still that good SGU is even better from
a production point of view and SGA is
just as beautifully produced as anything
on our television screens today so they
cannot do a hard reboot and I am
confident they won't but obviously it's
a risk but to be honest it's a risk with
Lego TV or movie I think it's just a
little bit more of a risk of the movie
way another big reason for bringing out
a big cinematic release is that
obviously again it will create the
impact it'll get all the advertising
that goes with a big cinematic release
and hopefully it will attract a load of
new viewers and at the end of the day us
skaters will go and watch this film
we'll go and watch this television
series and no bother you don't have to
ask us twice
but other people might need asking they
might need convincing a TV series can do
that you've got 10 hours say to excite
people and to get people hooked but it
will not get the advertising on
television posters etc etc that a movie
will so if you want to attract new
people to the franchise and we do
regardless of what you think about this
sort of thing if we want the franchise
to actually succeed and for us to get as
much Stargate as possible we need it to
be popular we need people to actually
watch it not just us Gators we need more
people to watch it a cinematic release
can do that it can attract new Gators to
the franchise
and then work into the TV series that we
really want because at the end of the
day
two hour experience
that'll be great and I'd love to go to
the cinema and eat my popcorn and drink
my Coke and watch Stargate on the big
screen again
I missed it first time around I was too
young but that would be my absolute
dream but then what I really really want
is 10 20 30 40 hours of Television to
follow it I want a series that really
develops characters that we get
introduced to on a big screen we want to
develop those characters we want to get
to know them we want to get to love them
in that television series
but the way we get to do that and the
way we get to see that as a long-term
project and not just you know a little
mini series is for us to have the big
franchise and to have a big franchise
you need the big movie and the other
thing is I genuinely think this is where
Amazon are going I've reported to you a
couple of times that Jennifer sulky
thinks this is the way to go and she is
the big cheese at MGM and Alison she's
the one that will be actually writing
the checks and agreeing this it is also
I believe why we're still waiting for an
announcement because they want to do a
movie first and until last week they
didn't actually have a chief executive
in charge of filming and streaming over
at MGM and Amazon the management team is
now in place and it looks like
that maybe we could be about to get a
decision on this but if it was just a
television series for MGM plus I
honestly think we'd have had that
decision by now but because they're
thinking about doing a movie first
it's taking a lot longer to actually get
that green light they're looking to
bring Stargate back as a big franchise
something that they will put front and
center that they want to challenge their
might of Star Trek and Star Wars with
and that's why this has taken so long
so
TV or movie first
movie go on you know you want to Amazon
to sign on the dotted line Jennifer
salkey sign on the dotted line get us
this in production please
please guys get in the comments to tell
us what you think TV series or movie
after listening to both arguments now
even though you know Matt's wrong he's
always wrong go comment on this video
shut up Matt it amuses him promise you
even though he's obviously wrong he
might have a point so what do you think
get in the comments and tell us both
exactly what's on your mind if you are
new to the Channel please like subscribe
hit that Bell notification really a
sound also you can go over to patreon
and become a full member there for a
small fee and for that small fee you'll
get most of our videos before YouTube
and you can watch them without the
adverts as always guys please stay safe
and I'll see you next time
okay now the final credits have gone
I can be honest with you we do these
little argumentative videos where you
know he ticks one side and I take the
other and I have to argue that I want a
movie before a television series
if Amazon are listening
don't do it if I have any influence over
you at all which I don't but if I did
don't do it do a television series
if you do a movie and it fails we've got
them all Stargate a television series is
way good less risky option and we get a
lot more actual like stuff for that so
yeah to do series please that'll be
lovely all right thank you thank you bye
[Music]